now if she's gonna have any chance of
getting her deal through the Prime
Minister needs to win support from right
across the political spectrum from the
arg2 union bosses and one of those that
she hopes to convince is the Labour MP
John Mann who joins us now from his
constituency in Notting Notting sure
thank you very much for being with us so
will you back the prime ministers deal
well a days a long time in politics or
things can change but as it stands it's
is like they'll vote for the deal yes
and how many other Labour MPs do you
expect to vote with the Prime Minister
well I
I don't expect if I do I don't expect to
be the only one I'd be surprised if it's
anything like enough to get this deal
through but things can change and you
need to remember I I voted leaving the
the referendum but more importantly I
voted to trigger article 50 I've voted
for the referendum in the first place
every single Labour MP apart from the
Honorable exception of Mike gates did so
and my manifesto that I stood on the
Labour manifest of this dog said we're
gonna see through the will of the people
and the referendum decision to leave the
European Union and so the that the
choices are going to get stacker and
there's there are some choices the
general election which labor wants is an
option I will support that option of
very happy to have a general election
but I don't see that getting a majority
in parliament and whether that would
resolve things whether there would be a
a Labour government with the large
enough majorities to see things through
is also clearly not known labour could
be in power causes just like treason as
a minority government but that's an
option that's an honest option there's
the option of having a referendum I
disagree with that option the the we've
given the people of vote that's not what
our manifesto said I'd be breaking our
manifesto but that's a clear option and
the other option is armory Trevelyan
czar so-called No Deal that's a bit of a
false option there's no such thing as No
Deal
the No Deal option actually means
thousands of deals into the future with
the Europe in you now give you an
example God raised a small matter
the grand national on the sixth of April
with a No Deal unless we have a deal
with the Irish then no Irish horses will
be coming to the grand national and if
we don't have a permanent deal either
with Ireland and Irish government or the
European Union and then British horse
racing collapses cuz there be no Irish
horses ever here again there will be
with no deal thousands of Till's with
the European Union
if you don't holiday to Spain then
there's a deal that will have to be done
over healthcare there's a dealer of a
repatriate bodies if someone sadly died
over and say Spain there's a deal over
how you get through customs the deal
whether you can take your dog there or
not and there are thousands of deals so
no deal actually is the wrong term and I
I think the mess and chaos and
uncertainty that will cause negotiate
and all those thousands of deals is the
worst option other than putting it off
because my constituents are saying and
get on with it
the worst of anything would be delay in
article 50 for me I just want to pick
you up on one thing that you said and in
that answer which is where that you vote
for a general election you'd be happy
for there to be a general election
because there'll be some people in the
labor movement who'll be looking at what
you're perhaps going to be doing and
which what we expect you to be doing
which is to vote for the Prime
Minister's deal and think that that is a
one thing that makes a general election
less likely and they're right aren't
they would they would be right you
effectively propping up a Conservative
government it's not problem becomes
Derby government's trying to get a a
structure of a deal through the you know
there'll be a confidence vote that could
have been one put already and when there
is that may trigger a generation I labor
doesn't have the votes to do that so
something's going to have to happen big
for that to get through but that's a
it's a perfectly honest legitimate
option I have a generation every year if
necessary not sure the public
appalled the my voters general action is
the least welcomed option the eight
percent of them appalled
5,000 responded 8% in favor of general
election so that's not where they're
coming from but general election is one
option but the Conservatives not going
to vote for a general election and
intriguingly uncomfortable with that is
of course in a general election jeremy
corbyn's made clear the Labour Party
will be going for brexit delivering
brexit in the general election the
intriguing thing is that if there is a
confidence vote some of the Labour MPs
were most ardent about a second
referendum at all costs we'll be voting
for a general election where that's not
going to be an option from the Labour
Party so that's that's an intriguing
dilemma for them but we've put an
amendment a group of us to the
government on labour law
environmental protections and Health and
Safety major red lines for us and the
the union leaders have all commented on
that I believe the promise even talked
to them about it and they've said the
problem with it is it's not legally
binding but well that's incorrect
because with the withdrawal act that has
to happen for this all to be seen
through then a legally binding
commitment to guaranteeing existing
rights on workers rights on
environmental protection on health and
safety
indeed on things like equality as well
is eminently possible and there's a
majority to do it I'm hoping that the
government says that they will back it
and they'll put it in but even if they
didn't we can put that in and that to me
is where this discussion this debate if
you like the negotiations needs to take
place to commit to get us through the
hurdle that the two main parties said
we'll we'll see through brexit because
that's what the the British people voted
for and that's where I think this needs
to go next and there's not much time but
there is enough time and and at some
stage I think that those kind of deals
ie
agreement of what's got a majority will
hold people together so don't think
bringing people together in this code
is now absolutely vital the South that
generally voted remain and the North
that generally vote to leave and a quick
cut thought from anywhere before we end
and you're talking about trying to get
agreement you went in to see the Prime
Minister this week did she give you any
indication that she was likely to accept
any of your requests yes
and specifically understanding that the
legislation not just a promise from the
Prime Minister but the legislation under
withdrawal Act will need to meet those
requirements and it's not just
guaranteeing the existing standards
because our our workers rights our
environmental protections are higher
than the European Union it's also
ensuring that they improve theirs that
government will be legally bound to
bring those proposals so that the House
of Commons Parliament can vote on them
and this is vital so for now don't
forget Sauve you know there is the
possibility that there could be at some
stage perhaps immediately or in the next
couple of years a minority labour
government in the same position as
Teresa may now is that Minority labour
government even a majority level don't
with a small majority spending its
entire time trying to construct brexit
or as it got those guarantees legally in
place in my view it's vital to do so
that we have leaving the European Union
a country that competes on the highest
standards not the lowest standards in
terms of pay and conditions that's the
kind of breaks that I want to see that's
the real choice do we have a race to the
bottom and try Nunda cuts everyone else
in the European Union on parent
conditions or do we have a race to the
top and we do it based on the highest
conditions the highest standards been
the best in the world that's the
opportunity that Parliament's got and I
want to see the government continue in
the next 48 hours to be responsive to
specific demands one of my colleagues
are know is in discussions with them
with others over the whole issue of
equality law let's have the highest
standards but let's have it legally
ending in the withdrawal act and let's
have that guarantee before Tuesday that
will move us on will it get the promise
to over the line I suspect not but it
takes us a lot nearer towards that okay
John man thank you very much